así es pues es una jornada que ha tenido
una participación abundante de la
ciudadanía como bien lo comentaba son 93
millones de ciudadanas y ciudadanos los
que fueron convocados este día a las
urnas y a pesar de que aún está la
pandemia de kobe 19 las medidas de
seguridad sanitaria que se tomaron han
funcionado bien en las casillas y ya
cerraron en todo el país y la autoridad
electoral ha salido a dar un primer
balance un primer balance en el que
califica la jornada de exitosa de las
162 mil 570 casillas únicamente 30 no
pudieron ser instaladas por algún motivo
de inseguridad esto es 99 puntos 73 por
ciento de las casillas se instalaron
correctamente y los mexicanos pudieron
salir a votar es cierto que ha sido un
proceso electoral marcado por la
violencia son más de 30 candidatos
asesinados en un proceso en el que
también ha habido agresiones
físicas secuestros amenazas y se
intensificaron hacia el final hacia la
recta final de las campañas ha sido
también un proceso electoral en el que
la intervención del presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador ha sido un factor
el mandatario asegura que es parte de su
libertad de expresión que él no puede no
informar en sus conferencias mañaneras
de lo que está ocurriendo y de cómo ve
el proceso electoral mismo sin embargo
pues ha habido más de 80 impugnaciones
de los partidos de oposición porque
consideran una injerencia una
intromisión del presidente en el proceso
electoral e incluso el tribunal
electoral del poder judicial federal y
en dos ocasiones señalado que en efecto
el presidente con los comentarios del
presidente en sus conferencias han pues
de alguna manera violentado en la avda
que hay para pronunciarse respecto a los
comicios
pues esto se ha convertido en una pugna
en realidad entre el ejecutivo y la
autoridad electoral tanto la
administrativa en este caso el instituto
nacional electoral como la judicial que
es el tribunal electoral sin embargo
bueno a pesar de todo ello a pesar de la
pandemia de la violencia de la pugna
entre la autoridad en este caso el
presidente con los organizadores de la
elección ha sido un proceso
participativo en la propia secretaria de
gobernacion olga sánchez cordero ha
dicho que la jornada transcurrió en paz
de manera pacífica y democrática sin
embargo no ha sido exenta de incidentes
focalizados algunos de ellos de cierta
gravedad hablamos por ejemplo en el
estado de mexico con la presencia de
grupos
claramente con el objetivo de entorpecer
de obstaculizar la jornada comicial de
grupos armados con palos con tubos en
algún municipio por ejemplo en naucalpan
si se identificó se logró detener a un
grupo en metepec también el estado de
mexico si llegaron a las agresiones a
los golpes incluso al destrozo en
algunas casillas o bien en tijuana la
ciudad fronteriza con eeuu se arrojó una
cabeza humana en una casilla de votación
para claramente intimidar a la población
el robo de urnas en oaxaca por ejemplo
se robaron 800 boletas electorales para
impedir desde luego la participación de
la ciudadanía sin embargo pues han sido
algunos incidentes que la propia
autoridad considera aislados focalizados
y que no han obstaculizado en términos
generales esta jornada electoral que
como bien lo mencionas
son de especial importancia para el
segundo la segunda mitad del mandato del
presidente lópez obrador porque está en
juego si en su partido morena y los
aliados el partido verde el pez y el pp
conservan la mayoría calificada que
ahora apenas si alcanzan con algunos
movimientos para poder llevar a cabo
reformas constitucionales las reformas
que el presidente aún quiere llevar a
cabo antes de terminar su mandato en el
senado hay que recordar no tiene la
mayoría calificada
y bueno es ahí donde reside la
importancia de estos comicios hay unos
estados algunas gubernaturas que son muy
disputadas es el caso por ejemplo de
nuevo león en donde el partido
revolucionario institucional pri se
disputa cara a cara con el partido
movimiento ciudadano ambos candidatos el
del pri adrián de la garza y el de
movimiento ciudadano samuel garcía han
salido a declararse vencedores en una
contienda puede más cerrada y así es el
caso en otras en otras jornadas en otros
estados donde
se renueva el poder ejecutivo estatal
aquí en la capital del país son 16 las
alcaldías que se renuevan y el congreso
local evidentemente y será a las 11 de
la noche cuando se conozcan los
resultados del conteo rápido que lleva a
cabo el ine el instituto electoral para
la cámara de diputados y para las quince
gubernaturas en juego